okay babies okay babies
it's your post psychobabble and we're
back we're back with a little dose of
rise of insanity and if you notice in
the title the S is red okay I don't know
what that means but it probably means
something you know think about it all
those letters and one letter is it
different color that's really new gaming
I don't know why it says continue I
always feel like people are like all
blah blah blah hey playing this already
no it just says continue but what I am
upset about is that you can't lower the
music usually the music is garbage and
games so I just lower always bottom and
keep the SFX but yeah yeah this do this
warning and this game contains scary
scenes and setting creases of tension
people with a weak heart
I feel like I should have read that but
I can't read fast enough okay okay
mm-hmm yes she said
okay I'll watch your little femme oh
hello Barney
hey nice some what birds some flames up
there and that looks good so far
there's some fire mixed in there I think
but what is that I see some red flying
through I imagine I don't know if that's
healthy I just probably that checked out
and okay
very nice anything in here and up there
anything and and here a patient Edward
with the three days one primer you and
ash like noses test a new therapy
waiting for results
mm-hmm it's always the gardener
hang a nice count check out here that is
I said here that Brayden Birds taxidermy
on your fifth birthday happy birthday
stamen what is that
pod yeah dad as a dad
oh yeah apartment okay that's
interesting
it's so nice trays out there okay okay
I like that way to get out of that FX
blur and it's a it's getting a little
you as head bomb
anything in here I'm offering an
investigator guy so let's check this out
dr. Dow launches a new coronal cheating
method watching stuff ya know that no no
no check out what's over there real
quick can I run there now what's in here
just as I thought
and I can't look in here it's like in
here now it's gonna take like ten hours
to run over there
can I go faster now well I have like
very limited controls it's a very polish
game now after win yeah this gesture is
laughing because his friend mr. tube
sock is telling him something funny
I'm sink five sink for Anson
just so just a bunch of crimes and
that's really what it is hey was that
Amanda's sympathy I don't head up like
that I don't know
and a doubt plays there now and again
there that's cricket why can I see
myself in here okay it'll go right here
so I like to peel off thorough in these
games is that a toxin what does that say
dear mrs. thou I'd like to money that he
gave me a free hand on the development
it's one part of the garden so I just
had to play mostly dollars identify
accentuated them with clematis flowers
or at a white peppers you'd be delighted
bad word okay so I wrote that I was I'm
miss Ella popping I guess well done
right now that some things will just
numb right now and it can we think in
here and up just John just jog just chug
just watch a junk in this game let me
tell you what is that stuff did our doll
great hey a medic
I'm mrs. Dow so I am the mother I think
we're in the Father and I know
now take it in Jim huh
okay
where's the phone I hear our phone but I
have no idea where it as where is it
I hear ringing is it out here no I'm
staying
what
[Music]
uh-huh their friend Abraham's that's one
that I have friends
nothing ten plays come to the mark to
help but they've been a vacation and it
K well why not boring office ooh that
guy dear darling Abraham chakra for a
long but busy so I wrote this to Abraham
currently have a patient Edward for when
his old he is probably but sleeping no
she has small ties that small tech
sometimes Helen each moves small finger
on his left hand he told me what his
nightmare that's tiresome but Sealand
remembers he's his charge kills his wife
with a child in it you do because he
wakes up before the end he strains that
or it's a passion until the hem and I
can't let anything about it
okay so he's obviously gonna try and
kill my wife I guess what is this
alcohol effect is a drug effect you know
I agree with that it is you're gonna go
crazy in here what's in here I would
like to know so I take this anything in
here sham I think fishing can be saved
perfect
you know you want me to come here how do
I always tell it why is it old on the
right is it right cutting that work any
a sec okay
go into the basement that's fine mmm
this is scaring yeah that's a scary
sound walking around over there I'll Rob
our duck game she doesn't know
all right so they wonder they're right
no did they go in here
no anything out right here nope nothing
at Kate our heart is located where your
journey began
what
a kata heart is located way our journey
began oh my god do I have to go to the
dates I don't know what that is place
that bass gaming well I'm actually going
crazy here what is that I really gotta
go all the way back someone's got a job
out here it's way too quiet it's way too
quiet I know it I know it I had to go
back I gotta go back down I all right oh
my god I got stuck let it down let me
get stuck around Zahra come on get them
on get though on you can do it yeah I
did it
alright what's gonna happen here is this
kind of oh my god Shay's us holy cannoli
yeah but they were not kidding when they
said it for the faint of heart
check eyesight room sex
well let's get deer on the wall but
that's not okay where I'm sex this is
gonna be scary let's do this gotta stand
up right here and look at this
o-69 and what's gonna happen now this is
terrifying I'm just gonna crawl my way
back 16 it was that always there a Mike
how crazy okay this isn't making I'm
gonna go inside
that's the rail rise to insanity it's
just some crookedy stuff great
alright we're just gonna run we're just
gonna run don't even look at anything
don't even look at that door yeah it's
fine
crap what was the number 69 is it don't
even open I'm even gonna look
not even gonna look what's in here
close this how is that noise lying there
Oh leave me alone I'm busy
no match
oh great they left okay this is getting
gross all right I definitely got
something something sec here okay
what that's horrifying okay what looks
like I made it
what is it with this bird guy okay he
sure I fly through this correctly am i a
bird yeah is that gonna heart yeah I
love it a lot of birds with my helipads
I write then I'm just on my way
I think I'm on the right way but yeah so
many parts here what's down there water
ah perfect
what is that Brett I love bread I guess
I'll take this I'm trying okay
not the managerial type all right well I
can tell you here next time - I'd watch
it yeah thank you